louchats y ambassadeur de chine en
france est convoqué ce mardi au quai
d'orsay une injonction au terme d'une
journée de frictions entre pékin et les
pays occidentaux sur le dossier épineux
des ouigours l'union européenne le
canada le royaume uni ainsi que les
états unis ont adopté ce lundi des
sanctions contre différents dirigeants
chinois du xinjiang la province du nord
ouest de la chine en majorité peuplée
par cette minorité musulmane en
représailles et qu'un s'en prend à dix
responsables européens parmi lesquels
l'eurodéputé raphaël glucksmann l'union
européenne a imposé des sanctions
unilatérales contre des personnes et
entités chinoises le 22 mars invoquant
la soi-disant problématique des droits
de l'homme au xinjiang
cette décision basée sur rien d'autre
que des mensonges et de la
désinformation ne tient pas compte et
déforment les faits et interfère
grossièrement dans les affaires
intérieures de la chine
la partie chinoise décide de sanctionner
ces dix personnes et quatre entités de
l'union européenne qui portent gravement
atteinte à la souveraineté et aux
intérêts de la chine et répondent de
manière malveillante des mensonges et de
la désinformation entre la france et la
chine
la confrontation diplomatique est montée
d'un cran dès vendredi
en cause des propos jugés inadmissibles
tenus la veille par l'ambassadeur à
l'égard d'un chercheur français jugé
trop critique envers pékin sur le
dossier taïwanais face à ces insultes
des experts en géopolitique ainsi que
des parlementaires ont pris la défense
du chercheur amenant le ministre
français des affaires étrangères à
réagir toujours sur twitter dans nos
relations avec la chine
il n'y a pas de place pour les insultes
et les tentatives d'intimidation contre
les élus de la république et des
chercheurs
nous défendons ceux qui incarnent la
liberté d'expression et la démocratie
toujours et partout
l'ambassade de chine en france est
coutumière de ces piques à l'encontre
des détracteurs de pékin louchats y
avait déjà été convoqué par le ministère
des affaires étrangères en avril 2020
après des écrits jugés déplacés
le message de
chine en france désormais éclair
l'époque où la chine encaissait sans
riposter est bel et bien révolue